dans le cadre de la préparation de notre
rapport sur l'adaptation des modes
d'action de l'État dans les autres mè
nous avons l'honneur et le plaisir de
recevoir Madame Brigitte gérardien
ancienne ministre de l'autreemè et
ancienne ministre délégué à la
coopération au développement et à la
Francophonie nous vous remercions Madame
la ministre d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et de venir répondre aux
questions de nos rapporteurs Philippe B
et Victor Lurel qui malheureusement ont
quelques petits soucis techniques ils ne
pourront pas se connecter ainsi qu'à
celle de nos collègues de la délégation
sénatoriale qui nous fait qui nous font
l'honneur de leur présence votre action
au ministère des outremè de 2000 à 2005
une longévité assez rare pour être
souligné a profondément marqué les
ultramarins vous aviez notamment déclaré
à l'époque aucun gouvernement n'a mené
une action aussi forte pour l'outrem
avec notamment une loi de programme sur
15 ans nous n'oublions pas aussi qu'une
loi importante porte votre nom supposé
prendre fin le 31 décembre 2017 la loi
Girardin a été prorogée jusqu'au 31
décembre 2025 pour les collectivités
d'outremer Polynésie française
saint-bartelémie Saint-Martin
Saint-Pierre et miclelan et waliss et
Futuna et et récemment pour les domes
Guadeloupe Guyane Martinique Mayotte et
la Réunion
nous sommes donc très intéressés par
votre expérience ministérielle le regard
que vous portez sur l'action publique en
outrem et naturellement sur les limites
et les obstacles que vous avez pu
rencontrer il nous a parut opportun de
recueillir votre témoignage sur la
méthode et les modalités d'intervention
que vous avez souhaité promouvoir les
résultats que vous avez obtenu et les
leçons que vous en tirez nous sommes
curieux en particulier d'entendre vos
observations par sur l'organisation des
concentré actuel de l'État l'adéquation
normative aux réalités des territoires
les moyens du ministère des outr-mèes ou
encore la diffusion d'une véritable
culture des
outrerses dans les ministères les sujets
ne manquent donc pas et vos réponses ne
manqueront pas de nourrir les
recommandations de nos rapporteurs sans
plus tarder je vais vous céder la parole
pour un exposé liminaire qui sera
ensuite suivi des questions de nos
collègues je
pr
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je voudrais tout
d'abord vous remercier moi aussi de me
donner cette occasion de vous faire part
de quelquesunes de mes
réflexions dans le cadre de cette étude
que je crois très importante que vous
menez au sein de la délégation sur
l'adaptation des modes d'action de
l'État
outrem je commencerai par vous dire que
le mot adaptation me paraît un peu
faible car j'ai la conviction que l'État
doit aujourd'hui profondément refonder
son action outreem après des années de
gestion au fil de l'eau sans véritable
vision à long
terme la crise du covid a été à mes yeux
un révélateur du malaise identitaire qui
couv outreè depuis de longues années et
qui doit nous amener aujourd'hui à nous
poser les bonnes
questions en effet pendant toutes ces
anné de ma vie professionnelle que vous
avez un peu
rappelé et que j'ai consacré à l'outrem
pendant une période effectivement assez
longue je n'avais jamais entendu dans un
CHU des Antilles ou d'une autre
collectivité ultramarine la France
dégage je partirai du principe que comme
le disait souvent Jacques Chirac l'outr
est une part essentielle de la France
car sans ces collectivités d'outrem la
France serait disait-il un pays
étriqué nous ne serions pas en effet la
deuxième puissance maritime du monde
nous ne serions pas présents sur tous
les continents mais que fait l'état
aujourd'hui pour mettre en valeur et
consolider ses
atouts est-ce que ces modes d'action
permettent à l'ensemble de la population
française de prendre conscience que nos
collectivités d'outrem sont une chance
et un atout extraordinaire pour notre
pays il est permis d'en douter tant les
clichés persiste sur le poids de la
charge budgétaire ou la niche fiscale
supposée quand vous me demandez quels
sont les handicaps de l'action de l'État
outrem que j'ai pu identifier dans mes
fonctions passées et dans quel domaine
je vous répondrai que le plus difficile
à faire comprendre et que chacune de ces
12 collectivités a des problématiques
différentes et qu'il faut sans cesse
faire du surmesure avec une approche
pleine
d'humilité à partir du constat sévère
que je fais sur l'action de l'État
outremer depuis une quinzaine d'années
je vous présenterai deux axes sur
lesquels cette action devrait me
semble-t-il non seulement être adaptée
mais profondément transformé
tout d'abord il me semble que l'État
doit se
réorganiser pour se concentré sur ses
missions régaliennes qu'il doit remplir
plus
efficacement l'outremè c'est compliqué
disait aussi Jacques
Chirac il faut donc une organisation
efficace de l'État avec des
fonctionnaires qui soient des
spécialistes de ces collectivités qui ne
peuvent être géré comme celles de
métropole
je ne vous sur surprendrai pas je pense
en vous disant qu'à Paris un ministère
de pleine exercice est une nécessité
absolue car l'émiettement des dossiers
ultramarins dans les différents
ministères ne peut qu'aboutir à la
négation des spécificités de l'outrem
qu'il faudra toujours prendre en compte
puisque ces collectivités connaissent
des handicaps
structurels liés notamment à
l'éloignement de la métropole
à l'insularité aux aléas climatiques à
l'étroitesse des marchés à la
concurrence de l'environnement régional
pour ne citer que
quelquesuns quand je mentionne un
ministère de plein exercice c'est à la
fois un ministre et une administration
qui lui est
rattaché Victorin Lurel et
moi-même avons à cet égard connu deux
situations très
différentes j'ai connu un ministère
composé de deux grandes directions avec
des fonctionnaires de grande qualité qui
avaient une connaissance très fine des
spécificités de
l'outrem Victorin Lurel est arrivé après
ce qu'il faut bien appeler l'entreprise
de démolition du ministère mené en 2007
où subsistait une vague délégation à
l'outrem qu'il a réussi à transformer en
direction générale mais sil faut mais il
faut bien reconnaître aujourd'hui que ce
qu'il reste d'administration spécialisé
sur l'outrem n'attire plus nos jeunes
fonctionnaires et qu'en réalité rares
sont ceux qui connaissent encore ces
collectivités la principale conséquence
c'est que les spécificités ultramarines
ne sont pas réellement prises en compte
dans la phase de conception de l'action
publique j'ai même l'impression qu'on
fait les choses à l'envers on écrit un
texte de loi et on prendensite des des
ordonnances pour le rendre applicable
outromère et il en est de même pour
l'organisation déconcentrée de
l'État par méconnaissance des
difficultés de servir outrem on affecte
ainsi aujourdhui dans nos collectivités
des préfets dont c'est le premier poste
et qui non seulement n'ont pas
l'expérience de la fonction mais ignore
que servir
outreem requière une présence sur tous
les
et des qualités d'écoute et de dialogue
avec la population tout à fait
exceptionnelle
entre mescnaissances et désintérêts
soulignz fort justement un article du
journal Le Monde de la semaine dernière
pour qualifier la politique menée
outreem comment dans ces conditions
retrouver une action de l'État efficace
outreem en particulier dans le domaine
régalien
je ne suis pas naïve et lorsqu'une
administration est supprimée il n'est
pas possible de la
recréer en revanche il serait peut-être
temps de considérer que l'action de
l'État outreem c'est aussi l'action de
l'État en
mer allons-nous continuer à tourner le
dos à 97 % de notre zone économique
exclusive j'ai eu l'occasion dans le
cadre d'un contrôle de la Cour des
comptes de pointer les carences de
l'organisation de de l'État en mer dans
nos collectivités
d'outrem alors que nous disposons d'une
organisation efficace pour les 3 % de
notre zone maritime autour de la
métropole avec trois grandes préfectures
maritimes à cherrebourg à Brest et à
Toulon nous n'avons aucun préfet
maritime outrem et nous avons outremer
une organ tion de l'action de l'État en
mer sur ces 97 % de zon économique
exclusive qui est totalement invisible
et
inefficace je précise que ce rapport de
la Cour des comptes de
2019 recommandé de transformer les trois
postes de comsup en Martinique à la
Réunion et en Polynésie française en
trois postes de préfet maritime sur ces
trois bassins Atlantique Océan Indien et
Pacifique et que lors de la phase
contradictoire puisque lorsqu'on fait un
contrôle à la Cour des comptes on envoie
dans un premier temps ses observations
provisoire aux différents ministères
concernés je tiens à souligner que lors
de cette phase contradictoire ni le
ministère de l'intérieur ni le ministère
de la Défense n'avait émis la moindre
objection à cette
recommandation une telle réforme
permettrait non seulement de mieux
contrôler notre immense domaine maritime
je pense au trafic de drogue au large
des des Antilles ou à l'immigration
illégale à Mayotte notamment mais de le
mettre en valeur en développant par
exemple des activités de pêche dans le
respect de la biodiversité
exceptionnelle de la plupart de ces
zones ou d'autres activités économiques
lié par exemple aux énergies
renouvelables en poursuivant dans cette
logique on pourrait créer un grand
ministère de l'outrem et de la mer qui
s'appuierait sur les différentes
administrations existantes et aurait
sans doute une attractivité nouvelle
pour notre fonction publique qui
pourrait ainsi acquérir une véritable
spécialisation le cœur des missions de
ce ministère concernerait
essentiellement les domaines
régaliens je ne vois bien sûr que des
avantages pour répondre à une
proposition qui vous a été faite à mieux
coordonner sur terre comme sur mer les
actions de notre police de nos armées de
notre justice mais aussi de nos douanes
dans le cadre d'une concertation
permanente entre les préfets et les
préfets maritimes comme cela se fait en
métropole faut-il par ailleurs comme
vous me le demandez renforcer le nombre
d'originaires dans les administrations
de l'État outremè en particulier dans
les forces de sécurité et la
justice je vous avoue que cette question
me met un peu mal à l'aise nos
compatriotes ultramarins fonctionnaires
ont vocation comme tous les
fonctionnaires de l'État français à
servir sur l'ensemble du territoire
français je ne suis pas sûr qu'affecter
prioritairement les policiers les
magistrats dans leur territoire
d'origine quand je dis leur territoire
d'origine je vise aussi la
métropole soit forcément une bonne chose
il faut en effet éviter de les mettre
dans des sites situation délicate par
exemple de conflit d'intérêts qui sont
très dommageables pour tous il faut
également ne pas freiner leurs promotion
qui passe aussi par des affectations
métropole qui présentent en outre
l'avantage de montrer la diversité
culturelle de notre
pays j'ajoute enfin que compte tenu de
l'importance géostratégique de ces
collectivité pour notre pays il serait
logique que l'outrem relève du domaine
réservé du président de la République je
me permets de dire que c'était la
conception qu'avait Jacques Chirac il
serait également souhaitable que le
ministère des Affaires étrangères
s'appuie plus fortement sur ces
territoires et leurs représentants pour
y développer une vraie politique
d'influence et une coopération régionale
plus
dynamique je ne sais pas ce que signifie
pour répondre à une de vos questions une
diplomatie des
outremerses pour moi il y a la
diplomatie de la France qui doit
utiliser ses collectivité ultramarine
comme relais de son action
internationale dans ces différentes
régions du monde par ailleurs il s'agit
de favoriser leur intégration dans leur
environnement géographique ce qui n'est
pas facile contenu des différences de
niveau de développement entre nos
collectivités et les pays de la région
je vis maintenant insister sur un
deuxième
axe je considère que l'État doit doter
les collectivités d'outremer de moyens
et de dispositifs
efficaces pour leur assurer un
développement économique et social
autonome j'évoqué tout à l'heure le
malaise identitaire révélé par la crise
covid nous avons déjà connu dans les
années 2000 une ond de crise identitaire
quand le débat statutaire faisait rage
aux Antilles en Guyane notamment ce qui
inquiétait souvent les populations et
lorsque l'État était accusé de maintenir
ses collectivités dans un assistanat
humiliant nous avions alors répondu en
2003 par une importante révision du
titre 12 de notre
Constitution qui permet à chaque
collectivité si sa population
l'prouve dans le respect des principes
de la République d'avoir un statut
différencié il s'agissait d'accorder
plus de responsabilité locale plus de
respiration démocratique pour
administrer ses collectivités de façon
plus adaptée au aux particularités
locales nous avions également fait voter
comme vous l'avez rappelé la loi de
programme de développement économique
d'une durée de 15 ans comportant
notamment un nouveau dispositifs de
défiscalisation et d'exonération de
charge
sociale j'ai la conviction aujourd'hui
qu'une nouvelle étape doit être
franchie comme je l'ai dit précédemment
l'État doit être plus fort et plus
présent sur ses missions régaliennes
mais il doit en revanche pouvoir
largement déléguer aux acteurs locaux
ses autres missions en affectant dans
chaque collectivité des dotations
financières par exemple en matière de
santé d'éducation par exemple
dont la liberté
d'utilisation ne serait limitée que par
le contrôle de l'égalité effectué
localement par la Cour des
comptes l'autonomie n'est pas un gros
mot et ne signifie en aucun cas un
désengagement financier de l'État ou une
absence de contrôle de l'utilisation des
fonds publics l'exemple polynésien en
est
l'illustration je rappelle que cette
collectivité qui est autonome en matière
de santé a bénéficié de vaccin contre le
covid entièrement financé par l'État
l'État doit accompagner
financièrement doit répondre aux
demandes d'envoi de personnel
métropolitain dans les hôpitaux et les
écoles mais ne doit plus imposer sa
politique dans les matières non
régaliennes c'est je crois la condition
pour reconstruire une relation de
confiance et de respect entre l'État et
ses collectivités
d'outremè c'est c'est aussi la condition
semble-t-il pour offrir à la jeunesse
ultramarine la possibilité de participer
à la gestion et à la gouvernance de son
territoire cette évolution nécessiterait
sans doute une fusion des articles 73 et
74 de la
Constitution en préservant bien sûr la
consultation de la population préalable
à tout évolution vers une autonomie qui
pourrait là encore être différenciée
selon les
collectivités lorsque l'on évoque
l'insuffisante adaptation normative aux
réalité de chaque territoire et les
exemples de normes inadaptées sont
nombreux comme dans le domaine par
exemple de la construction il semble
alors évident que les possibilités
d'adaptation contenues dans l'article 73
sont non seulement insuffisante mais
difficile à mettre en œuvre en raison
d'une procédure lourde et contraignante
il est temps me semble-t-il de laisser
aux acteurs locaux le soin de définir
eux-mêmes les réglementations les mieux
adaptés à leur
territoire pour assurer ce développement
économique et social autonome outre les
dotation financière globale par secteur
il me semble que l'État devrait mettre
en place un nouveau dispositif de
défiscalisation et d'exonération de
charg social car comme vous l'avez
rappelé on ne peut plus continuer
a prolonger chaque année la loi de 2003
qui était prévue pour 15 ans
c'est-à-dire jusque jusqu'en 2018
normalement ou fin 2017 je rappelle que
malgré les sérieux coups de rabau portés
à cette loi à partir de
2007 son prolongement et la
démonstration que pour compenser les
handicaps structurels des économie
ultramarine qui renchérissent le coût du
capital et celui du travail les outils
les plus efficaces restent encore une
défiscalisation très contrôlée par
l'État avec une procédure d'agrément dès
le premier euro et des exonérations de
charg social bien
ciblé mais il faut là aussi innover en
faisant du
surmesure c'est-à-dire ne plus mettre en
place des mesures uniforme de
défiscalisation et d'exonération de
charge sociale sans tenir compte des
secteurs concernés et des priorités de
développement qui sont différentes selon
les
territoires au-delà d'un socle commun à
tous les autres maires et qui
concernerait par exemple les projets
d'investissement utilisant des énergies
renouvelables qui devrait alors
bénéficier de taux très avantageux de
défiscalisation chaque collectivité
devrait pouvoir bénéficier de mesures
différenciées selon sa propre stratégie
de
développement si je prends l'exemple du
tourisme il est clair qu'il doit être
plus soutenu dans des collectivités qui
n'ont pas d'autre choix d'activité
économique comme les Antill ou la
Polynésie française que dans cell qui
disposent de ressources minières comme
la Nouvelle-Calédonie ou la Guyane il
conviendrait également de rendre
éligible à ces dispositifs certaines
activités comme la rénovation hôtelière
indispensable pour lutter contre la
concurrence des États voisins
ou certaines opérations de démolition de
friche et de reconstruction aux normes
antisismiques en résumé pour être plus
efficace l'État doit éviter le spoudrage
cibler les secteurs les plus porteurs et
moduler les mesures selon les priorités
de développement définies dans chaque
collectivité je rappelle que l'objectif
est avant tout de faciliter la création
d'emploi dans le secteur marchand
je terminerai en évoquant la nécessité
pour l'état de mieux accompagner nos
collectivités d'outrem dans
l'utilisation des fonds européens qu'il
s'agisse des fonds structurels ou du
Fond Européen de
Développement compte tenu de la
complexité et de la grande technicité
que requiert le montage de projets
éligibles il serait souhaitable que dans
chaque collectivité une structure ad hoc
soit mise en place auprès du préfet en
partenariat avec les autorités locales
pour faciliter la mise en œuvre de ses
financements dont le montant n'est pas
négligeable et n'est malheureusement pas
toujours
utilisé voilà les quelques
réflexion que je voulais partager avec
vous j'ajouterai qu'étant
personnellement toujours très attaché à
l'aoutreem je ne vous cache pas que
l'inadaptation actuelle de l'action de
état dans ses collectivités me paraît
très préoccupante je vous
remercie je te laisse
mer merci Madame madame la
ministre je vais laisser la parole à
notre rapporteur Philippe Bas et puis
ensuite à Victorin Lurel qui est en
ligne me semble-t-il Victorin vous nous
entendez je vous entends avec un peu de
de retard et je m'en excuse à tout de
suite merci
Victor madame la Présidente je vous
remercie c'est avec beaucoup de plaisir
et d'intérêt que je retrouve ce soir
Brigitte
Girardin auquel me lit une histoire
commune auprès de du président Jacques
Chirac qui comme elle l'a
rappelé a toujours a été un grand ami de
l'outreem euh et de nos compatriotes
d'outreemè qui était
euh toujours très présent dans son cœur
euh nous abordons
euh cher Brigit Girardin euh un
travail qui ne repose pas principalement
sur
l'idée d'une augmentation même si nous
ne l'excluons pas des
pouvoirs qui sont
conférés aux collectivités d'outremè aux
éd d'outrem mais qui porte
spécifiquement sur la manière dont
l'état remplit sa propre fonction or la
fonction de l'état restera fonction
économique vous l'avez mentionné mais
aussi
régulatrice et nous partageons déjà
alors que nous n'en sommes qu'au début
de notre
réflexion cette idée que vous
avez
énoncé que il y a tout de même un
problème
général de
d'adaptation des lois et des décrets en
réalité de l'outrem ils ne sont pas
imagin en fonction de ses réalités il
faut pas s'étonner que il y a un
décalage et nous
recherchons le
moyen non pas par des transferts de
compétences régulatrices aux élus même
si elles sont toujours possibles mais
par le
transfert
de
possibilité d'adaptation des normes par
l'État lui-même
d'améliorer dans le domaine de la
sécurité dans le domaine pénal dans le
domaine de la répression dans le domaine
de lutte contre les fraudes l'efficacité
de l'État
et au fond ma question vraiment d'ordre
très
général c'est est-ce
que vous
avez pu développer dans ce domaine une
une réflexion sur le pouvoir de
dérogation des autorités de l'État sur
les pouvoirs spécifiques des procureur
sur l'évolution du code de procédure
pénale qui pourrait nous éclairer dans
ce dans cette réflexion que nous
amorçons et qui va se déployer à la
Délégation aux outr mè pendant toute
cette année
merci beaucoup cher
Philippe je crois qu'il faut bien
distinguer le rôle de l'État dans les
matières régaliennes et dans les autres
matières et dans les matières
régaliennes je crois que les difficultés
que nous rencontrons depuis quelques
années sont très clairement liés au fait
que l'administration en
général a perdu beaucoup de compétences
sur la réalité
ultramarine et donc si on ne s'attaque
pas au problèm à la source c'est-à-dire
avoir une administration qui connaissent
outreem qui soit composé de spécialistes
de
l'outreem on n arrivera pas je veux dire
comme je l'ai rappelé au début de mon
propos moi j'ai eu la chance de
connaître un minist re de plein exercice
avec deux grandes directions composé de
de fonctionnaires qui connaissaient
l'outreem qui avait une expérience en la
matière et qui était capable d'alerter
les pouvoirs publics de dire attendez
vous allez prendre une loi dans tel ou
tel secteur mais il faut prendre en
compte le fait que cette loi elle va pas
être applicable comme ça autreemère
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus c'est pas
une question de dire est-ce qu'on met un
ministre de plein exercice un ministre
délégué un secrétaire état le problème
c'est qu'un ministre sans administration
ça ne sert à rien bon donc aujourd'hui
on a plus d'administration je rappelais
que Victorin et moi on a connu deux
situations différentes quand Victorin
Lurel est arrivé à la tête du ministère
de l'outremè il n'avait même plus il
avait une vague une vague délégation il
a essayé de la transformer en direction
générale parce qu'il a pris conscience
de de la nécessité de pouvoir s'appuyer
sur des services compétents mais
aujourd'hui on a d'abord nos nos
fonctionnaires ne sont plus du tout
attirés par par ces dossiers donc on a
une dgom je crois qu'elle s'appelle
comme ça qui qui puis alors maintenant
il y a plus que ça en ce moment ça fait
un mois que il y a plus rien bon
donc bon
donc le problème il vient de là je veux
dire on peut pas s'occuper de ces
collectivités avec un ministre qui est
rattaché à un autre ministère d'ailleurs
on voit l'efficacité du rattachement au
ministère de l'Intérieur je pense que
Mayotte est bien placé pour le savoir
euh on aurait pu se dire ah bah enfin
les problèmes de sécurité vont être
mieux réglés on voit bien que c'est pas
le cas bon donc il faut réellement une
administration solide et avec à sa tête
un ministre qui est du poids et pour
avoir du poids et j'en j'en ai fait
l'expérience moi-même si on a pas le
soutien du président de la République on
ne fait rien parce que les arbitrages
avec Bercy on sait ce que c'est
et voilà donc de deux choses l'une soit
on considère et là je suis désolé mais
soit on a une vision goliste de de de de
ce que c'est la grandeur de la France
soit on considère comme disait Jacques
Chirac que la France on ses
collectivités ce serait un pays étriqué
bon à partir du moment où on est tous
d'accord pour dire on a la France a un
rôle à jouer dans le monde à une voix
qui doit porter dans dans dans sur tous
les continents bon et bien il faut tenir
compte du relais indispensable que nous
avons avec nos 12 collectivités
d'outrem bon si on veut euh que ces
collectivités soi gérées
correctement joue ce rôle d'influence
dans le monde au nom de la France bah je
suis désolé il faut une administration
efficace et une administration efficace
c'est des fonctionnaires compétents qui
ont envie de s'intéresser à ces sujets
et aujourd'hui qui est-ce qui a envie
d'aller servir à la
dgom chaque fonctionnaire a envie
d'avoir aussi une carrière évoluée voilà
donc je pense
que il faut commencer par par se poser
cette question et et se concentrer dans
un premier temps sur le régalien parce
que effectivement tout ce qui
est c'est
sécurité
justice police douane tout ça on se rend
compte avec avec une zone économique
immense donc 97 % se trouve outreem on
se rend compte qu'il faut absolument que
toutes ces missions régaliennes soient
non seulement renforcé mais qu'on ait
les moyens de de vraiment de les remplir
correctement je j'ai eu l'occasion je
l'ai rappelé peut-être avant donc tu AR
je sais pas si tu as entendu mais que
euh j'avais eu l'occasion de travailler
à la Cour des comptes sur l'organisation
de l'État en mer et que l'organisation
de l'État en mer dans nos collectivités
d'outrem c'est catastrophique c'est
catastrophique on n pas de préfet
maritime on a trois préfets maritimes
pour 3 % de la zone économique en
métropole et on a aucun préfet maritime
sur 97 % de la zone économique je donne
un exemple quand il y a eu le cyclone
Irma bon euh quand je suis allée sur
place dans le cadre de ce contrôle de la
Cour des comptes mais attendez que le
préfet de Martinique m'a expliqué qu'il
était sur le papier en charge de
l'organisation de l'État en mer que
c'est lui qui devait aller prendre des
arrêtés pour interdire la mer
territoriale au large de la
Guadeloupe dans telle période pour
permettre l'acheminement des secours
pour Saint-Martin et euh le préfet de la
Guadeloupe lui euh n'avait aucune
compétence en la matière donc tout ça
n'a aucun sens et les préfets outremè je
vous assure qu'ils sont suffisamment
occupés avec tous les problèmes qu'il y
a sur terre pour s'occuper de ce qui se
passe en mer où ils n'ont pas de
compétences particulière et et où les
préfets maritimes ce sont des amiraux et
et ce sont des gens qui qui qui qui ont
la compétence nécessaire et en plus
cette réforme je dirais elle ne coûte
rien elle est simple à mettre en œuvre
il suffit de transformer les trois
comsup en trois préfets maritimes
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que le général comsup qui est à la
Réunion il suffit de le remplacer par un
amiral puisque à papété comme à Fort de-
France on a deux amiraux déjà bon donc
vraiment alors commençons par avoir une
administration efficace avec des
fonctionnaires qui soient spécialisés et
là je pense qu'on pourra
anticiper tous les problèmes
d'adaptation et et et qu'on pourra et
non pas comme on le fait actuellement on
fait tout à l'envers on on on fait des
lois puis après on se rend compte que
c'est pas adaptable à l'outre mer alors
on essaie de faire des ordonnances on
est on on fait vraiment du bricolage
donc voilà un peu déjà la façon dont je
vois les choses bon maintenant il y a
toute la problématique parce que je sais
que c'est une question qui taraude un
peu les les les ultramarins sur lesquel
je dis que je suis pas très à l'aise de
dire et sur en matière de sécurité et de
justice est-ce qu'il faut favoriser
euh le les Français originaires d'outrem
à occuper ses postes dans leur
territoire je sais qu'il y a il y a des
demandes c'est un sujet délicat moi j'ai
tendance à dire
que tous les
fonctionnaires français ont vocation à
servir sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est valable pour l'outreem comme pour
la métropole bon et je me permets de
souligner que lorsqu'on parle de
magistrat lorsqu'on parle de de policier
il faut faire très attention au conflit
d'intérêt
et et en même temps il faut faire très
attention à ce que nos compatriotes
ultramarins puissent avoir aussi qu'
sont fonctionnaires puissent avoir un
déroulé de carrière normal et que les
promotions passent souvent par une
affectation en métropole et que d'autre
part c'est important aussi de donner
l'image en métropole de la diversité
culturelle de la France donc voilà ce
que je voudrais pas être trop longue
là-dessus mais moi je pense qu'il faut
commencer par se doter de d'une
administration efficace et ce qui n'est
plus le cas malheureusement
aujourd'hui merci merci je vais laisser
la parole à Victor Lurel
oui merci est-ce que vous m'entendez et
est-ce que vous me voyez alors on entend
mais on vois pas très bien on va tenter
de faire pour le mieux je commence par
présenter des excuses à toutes et à tous
et en particulier à notre ministre brgit
Girardet que je retrouve avec grand
plaisir j'avoue que j'ai quelques
problèmes avec mes yeux c'est la raison
pour laquelle je savais même pas si
j'aurais pu voir l'écran je reviens de
chez le le médecin alors j'ai pas tout
entendu mais ce que j'ai entendu j'avoue
je partage totalement ce qu'a pu dire
notre ministre Brigit Girardin et Dieu
seul sait combient je me suis opposé à
Brigit Girardin en 2003 et c'est grâce à
brgit Girardin qu'on a pu réformer la
Constitution en tout cas le volet
outremer et dont on a vu l'utilité
aujourd'hui et certains d'ailleurs et
j'en fais partie demandent à aller un
peu plus loin alors c'est vrai que notre
délégation a délimité le périmètre re de
notre travail euh à savoir l'action de
l'État et en particulier centré disons
d'abord sur les domaines régaliers mais
j'avant en
écoutant Brigit
Gérardin fort de fort de son expérience
et de ce que moi-même j'ai vécu au
ministère je partage totalement ce
qu'elle a dit euh si on devait et on
doit le faire
approfondir l'action de l'État dans ces
domaines m à constitution constante et
disons-le peut-être à administration et
et organisation territoriale constante
je suis arrivé moi depuis de longues
années à la conclusion euh qu'il faut
aller plus loin que le domaine constant
euh et qu'il faut probablement donner
plus de moyens et peut-être de liberté
au aux élus avec bien entendu les
contrôles appropriés euh et les
contrepouvoirs qui
s'imposent oui elle a tout à fait raison
quand je suis arrivé après application
de la RGPP c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelait à l'époque on a carrément
démantelé le ministère il ne restait
plus je crois à l'poque 130 et quelques
personnes dans une seule
délégation
délégation et j'ai dû
ferrailler comme disait l'autre me
battre pour que ce soit transformer en
direction et je peux vous assurer que
euh on a eu du mal à faire venir de
grands directeurs des fonctionnaires
d'expertise de bon niveau parce qu'ils
n'y voyaient pas leur carrière euh
c'était un ministère qui n'était pas
très attractif et ça l'IT toujours euh
il faut le dire et et et et les deux
directions ont été transformé dansune
délégation aujourd'hui on n'a pas
rattrapé euh le les en fait le ministère
de l'Intérieur euh de l'époque a fait sa
RGPP sur le compte et sur le dos du
ministère des outrem euh il y a eu près
d'une centaine de départs qui n'ont
jamais été remplacés et aujourd'hui
c'est vrai euh au-delà de la question
qui est posée sur l'action de l'État
faut-il encore au ministère des
outremèes j'avoue moi-même avoir cédé à
cette lubi un moment de dire et bien euh
pour l'égalité supprimons le ministère
j'ai écrit ça je crois en 2007 avec
François Hollande c'était une bêtise et
j'en suis revenu d'ailleurs ça avavait
pas vraiment bousculé les état-majors de
parti on en est revenu alors un
ministère comment et bien oui elle a
bien raison il faut des moyens quels que
soi les périmètres de l'action de l'État
il faut des moyens il faut un personnel
et on y a ajouté quelques années plus
tard et je croyez-moi je je je ne
regarde pas aux couleurs politiqu parce
que les socialistes ont fait les mêmes
bêtises j'ai dû plaider pour avoir de
direction et avoir de vrais moyens ça
n'a pas prospéré euh on a fait la bêtise
de supprimer le ministère de la
coopération qui avrait une vraie
administration de vraies connaissances
sur l'Afrique et et et et l'hémisphère
sud j'ai même écrit un livre pour
dénoncer ça et et et et vu j'ai vu des
présidents de la République de ne pas
faire ça c'est c'est un savoir qui
disparaît c'est une connivance c'est des
amitiés des relations des cultures qui
disparaissent et bien l'utre mère subit
aujourd'hui depuis quelques longues
années le même sort avec des
fonctionnaires qui font leur travail
mais qui n connaissent pas grand-chose
et qui n'y voi pas leur avenir et donc
oui il faut donc un ministère de plein
exercice je partage la vie qui consiste
pour une action efficace de l'État que
le ministre qui est nommé là doit être
un bon politique il doit avoir l'oreille
du président de la République je
rappelle pour la petite histoire j'ai dû
démissionner deux fois présenter ma
démission lorsque Bercy voulait me faire
faire 180 millions d'euros d'économie
lorsqu'on m'a voulu m'imposer un certain
nombre de choses de supprimer des lycées
à pointbout et à mondo en
Nouvelle-Calédonie j'ai dû présenter ma
démission j'ai dû présenter ma démission
parce que j'avais fait le programme de
François Hollande pour les autres mèes
lorsque il a refusé de corriger si je
dire de contrôler total sur euh euh les
marges de Total euh avec 32 millions de
dollars chaque année investi au Bahamas
dans les Bermudes euh j'ai dû lui
montrer les éléments en disant je ne
céderai pas à ça et bien aujourd'hui
j'entends qu'on va réformer les le
décret sur les marges et sur la fixation
des prix administrer des carburants
c'est peut-être une bonne chose avec les
trois arrêtés de méthodes mais là à
l'époque il fallait un poids politique
et j'avais dit au président j'accepte
d'être ministre des outres mè à
condition que ça s'appelle ministre des
autres Mair premièrement deuxièmement je
choisi mon directeur de cabinet on
m'imposait quelqu'un j'ai refusé et et
troisièmement je veux des référents dans
chacun des ministères ça s fait certains
ministres étaient pas très content mais
chaque trimestre je crois je réunissais
tous les référents de tous les ministère
pour savoir ce qui se préparait et donc
un ministère sans moyens et un ministère
avec un ministre qui n'a pas l'oreille
du Premier ministre et surtout du
président de la République je peux vous
dire ça galère ça galère et ensuite oui
il faut une personnalité pour pouvoir se
faire entendre connaître ses dossiers
enfin euh euh
euh j'ai repris ce qu'avait fait
Brigitte Girardin je l'avoue après
l'avoir fortement critiqué en tant que
député en l'époque en cette qualité-là
euh j'avoue avoir demandé la stabilité
fiscale qu'elle avait euh euh instauré
15 ans pour une loi de programme et bien
qu'on a démontré tous les gouvernements
quel que soit le couleur après chaque
année en chaque loi de finances il y
avait une instabilité et je l'avoue une
incompréhension de toutes les majorités
parlementaires quel que soit ces
majorité là euh donc stabilité on na
jamais plus retrouver ça euh euh je euh
euh je l'avoue ensuite euh cette action
pluri-annuelle euh des lois de programme
ou d'orientation qui donnait une vision
que j'ai reprise dans une loi égalité
réelle sur 20 ans euh avec des euh
contrats de convergence sur 5 ans on les
appelle maintenant de convergence et de
transformation ajouté par Madame Annick
girérardin mais très bien mais ça n'a
pas eu d'effet parce que on a refusé
d'appliquer euh les principes qui
figuraient alors je le regrette mais si
on veut avoir une vision complète et
bien il faut une vision à long terme
ensuite ce qu'elle dit sur la l'action
de l'État en maire moi j'ai repris sur
sa ses conseils parce que Gardin
peut-être se le rappelle elle me l'avait
dit au téléphone en disant mais Lurel il
faut des préfectures maritimes j'ai
repris ça j'ai présenté ça ça n'a pas
fait bouger les ministères ni les
gouvernements en disant mais c'est une
chose de bon sens qu'il y ait des
préfectures maritimes trois préfectures
maritime d'autant plus qu'elle vient
d'en donner un peu euh la la solution ça
coûtera pas plus cher il est vrai euh
quand on prend le Pacifique et quand on
sait l'immensité des euh euh euh euh
océans euh il faut se battre dans la loi
de programmation militaire aujourd'hui
on m'avait dit à l'époque on n pas trop
de bâtiments pour couvrir ces surfaces
et bien on va le faire par une
couverture satellitaire euh ben
aujourd'hui euh je sais pas ce que font
les satellites pour contrôler tous les
pillages faits par les autres puissances
euh en ressources éologique maritime et
et et tout ce qu'on peut imaginer l'état
est défaillant c'est une évidence là
peut-être que c'est trop grand peut-être
que on n pas pris conscience encore des
changements géopolitiques alors
peut-être oui après ce qui s'est passé
en Australie sur les sous-marins ce qui
se fait avec la Chine aujourd'hui entre
la Chine et des États-Unis on prend con
ce qui se fait sur les intérêts que
pourrait susciter certains pays la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et d'autres alors oui
peut-être qu'il y a une réorientation à
opérer pour l'action de l'État outremire
je suis pour ma part convaincu au-delà
de ce que mon collègue Philippe B vient
de dire il ne faut pas que nous nous
enfermions totalement dans le seul
existant dans le périmètre qui est
aujourd'hui le N tel qu'on le connaît
euh j'entends une ministre qui m'a
précédé et moi-même ayant vécu ça mais
on pourrait interroger d'autres de voir
que à dimension constante à organisation
constante pour le moment à à
constitution constante les choses ne
bougent pas alors est-ce les élus locaux
qui seraient des incapables est-ce que
parce que ils n'ont pas suffisamment de
moyens ce que je ne croit pas qu' n'ont
pas utilisé la totalité des moyens qui
leur sont délégués c'est possible il
faudra peut-être que notre délégation
approfondisse la question je suis
convaincu qu'une petite dose euh euh de
liberté supplémentaire qu'une
domiciliation supplémentaire de pouvoir
en subsidiarité c'est-à-dire le mieux
placé pour agir agir je suis convaincu
que c'est de nature améliorer l'action
et de l'État et des collectivités bref
ce qui constitue l'État au sens général
euh euh du terme mais bon il faut
approfondir la première phase à savoir
est-ce que l'État aujourd'hui agit
efficacement quand on prend le pouvoir
des préfets l'a évoqué on a donné des
pouvoirs supplémentaires au préet en
matière d'immigration euh je crois que
mes collègues de Mayotte sont là si mes
yeux me permettre de bien voir euh on a
des pouvoirs ils ont des pouvoirs
autrement plus importants qu'un préfet
de l'Hexagone euh un préfet peut faire
euh expulser peut faire des qtf euh en
are ma avant même la saisine du tribunal
administratif et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
des drames chez moi en Guadeloupe on a
expulsé une vingtaine euh de de de de
d'Haïtiens c'est c'est c'était le cas et
l'avion s'est craché en mer euh à
l'époque mais euh si ça se fait en
France et je peux vous dire les barreaux
les avocats toutes C tous ceux qui
s'occupe de la défense des droits de
l'Homme critique cette affaire- làà
j'avoue qu'on est assez discret tous les
a mais quand on parle d'immigration on
évoque pas ça vraiment et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et bien on fait ce qui existe
déjà quand l'État s'occupe de ces euh
actions de ces domaines les élus ne sont
pas là euh quand il s'agit de justice on
n'est pas là quand il s'agit de
régaliens les élus ne sont pas informés
si ce n'est de manière fort subsidiaire
l'État reste dans un Huos euh entre
c'est un entre soi étatique euh et je
peux vous dire il faut galérer pour
demander ce qui qui se passe en matière
des affaires de l'État je prends un cas
sur les conventions de réadmission quand
l'État monsieur Sarkozi était candidat à
l'élection présidentielle alors ministre
de l'utre de l'intérieur il est venu
partout dans les autres mes après ce qui
s passé moi je l'avais reçu en
Guadeloupe en disant vous êtes en
République et vous êtes libre de venir
ici au-delà de vos prises de position
sur les bienfaits de la colonisation on
l'a reçu il discutait avec le Premier
ministre de la de la Dominique
anglophone monsieur rel skit et on était
pas au courant et on parlait de
réadmission que chaque Haïtien ou chaque
étranger en situation irrégulière arrêté
sur le sol de de la Martinique de la
Guadeloupe peut-être de Saint-Martin je
sais pas et de saint-martelemi on va
pouvoir les renvoyer en Dominique ou à
saintti et qu'il fallait donc payer ces
réadmissions là je crois savoir c'est
peut-être la même chose à à mayott il
faudrait faire un diagnostic j'ai dû
attendre 2 ans pour qu'on accepte de me
donner la convention de réadmission mais
depuis lors personne n'a fait le bilan
de tout ça manifestement il y a à mon
sens une révaluation de de de l'action
de l'État dans son périmètre actuel et
peut-être dans un éventuel élargissement
avec plus de contre-pouvoir j'ai voté
contre une collectivité unique parce qu'
il y avait pas de contre-pouvoir et
j'avoue ce que je vois moi en Martinique
et en Guan sans critiquer les élus qui
ont accepté euh je ne veux pas de chez
moi au welou parce que je veux des
contrepouvoirs par exemple un statut de
l'opposition
euh des un temps programmé la
reconnaissance des groupes d'opposition
ce qui reste une faculté aujourd'hui
c'est la démocratie elle-même qui est
euh mal représenté et qui n'est pas
suffisamment efficace bref il y a à dire
et ce qu'a pu dire Brigitte Gérardin ce
que j'ai entendu je partage vraiment
totalement euh ces positionsl sous
réserve véritablement de vérifier au
cours de notre travail comment
l'intégrer comment peut-être demander
avec prudence l'élargissement c'est ce
pourquoi j'ai fait des propositions à
notre présidente de délégation j'ai fait
des propositions au président Larché et
à je crois Jean Noël buffet sur le
travail de révision et de
différenciation pour qu'il y ait un
volet outrem voilà je suis déjà beaucoup
trop long mais j'étais content
d'entendre Gérard voilà merci chers
collèg
donc sans plus tarder je vais laisser la
parole à notre
collègue
mohamedali merci beaucoup madame madame
la
Présidente merci Madame la la ministre
pour votre analyse et et vos
propositions très claires très précises
auxquelles en ce qui me concerne
j'adhère à 100
% j'ai hâte de de les voir dans le
rapport sans m'avancer je suis pas
rapporteur et surtout de voir dans
quelle dans quelle mesure nous pourrions
les faire avancer pour que euh au final
ell soit elles soit adopté
euh j'aimerais revenir sur deux trois
points
euh pas forcément pour poser des
questions mais pour prolonger le débat
l'analyse
lorsque vous vous préconisez euh qu'il
faille instaurer un ministère de plein
exercice euh que pensez-vous
h de la situation actuelle quelle que
soit
euh le le ministère de plein exercice
secrétaire d'État ministère délégué mais
une situation qui fait que ce
ministère ne gère que 10 % des crédits
outrem
euh les
90 % restant étant régis par les autres
ministères
régalien est-ce qu'il y a une pertinence
à ce que cette situation perdure ainsi
est-ce
que le problème ne réside pas
également dans cette dans cette
répartition
et ayant posé cette problématique je me
pose la question
question de l'utilité de la persistance
d' ministère des autres
mèes je suis d'accord avec ce que vous
avez dit que il faudrait des
spécialistes de ces sujets des
connaisseurs de ces
sujets non seulement s'agissant des
préfets mais aussi s'agissant des
ministères des administration et est-ce
que il ne serait pas plus pertinent de
dire que effectivement dans
notre République euh tous les les
territoires euh se Val sont sont égaux
et que euh peu importe les spécificités
parce qu'en matière de spécificité nous
pourrions reparler de la Corse nous
pourrions reparler de l'Alsace Mosel euh
on ne réserve pas un
ministère à des territoires parce qu'ils
sont spécifiques parce qu'ils sont euh
éloignés et que c'est territoires comme
les autres
euh et bien négocie traite directement
avec chaque ministère mais pour marquer
cette spécificité euh on on met au sein
des administrations
euh central de ces ministères des
personnes spécialisées et on nomme
effectivement des préfets euh plus que
connaisseur euh de cette de de de de la
particularité des des autres mèes c'est
une première observation
euh un deuxième point relatif aux
originaire j'entends bien vos réserves
par rapport au principe d'égal
traitement entre tout euh entre tous les
Français mais ce qui se passe c'est
que des
ultramarins euh après
avoir
suivi les les les examens les concours
comme n'importe quel autre compatriote
et bien on l'impression et c'est ce
n'est pas qu'une impression de de rester
euh immobilisé
pendant une période extrêmement longue
dans une région de l'hexagone et ils
n'ont pas la possibilité
euh de de de retourner euh dans dans
leur territoire et ce alors même que ces
territoires pour une raison
d'attractivité et bien peuvent manquer
de de de candidats euh notamment en
matière de de sécurité en matière de de
force de l'ordre pour aller euh prêter
leur concours euh à à leurs
collègues à leurs collègues en autre m
donc il y a une question de fluidité une
question de euh de de de circulation
euh parce
que la la logique voudrait aussi moi je
je suis je suis d'accord avec le
principe que vous avez rappelé voudrait
aussi que et bien des collègues de
l'Hexagone
aillent partout dans la République y
compris y compris un are ma et que la
circulation soit aisée soit facile pour
tout le monde mais pas qu'il y ait cette
impression de blocage
euh des originaires des ultramarins dans
l'hexagon ou dans les autres régions
d'ùt ils ne sont pas originaires
et une forme de d'injustice est ressenti
donc c'est c'est ça c'est ça que que je
voulais toucher toucher du doigt et
c'est pour ça que ces demandes ces
revendications pour que les mutations
des originaires soient plus facilité se
font se font jour et et je pense qu'il y
a quelque chose à faire entre les deux
entre le principe d'égal traitement de
tous les fonctionnaires de tous euh les
les les concitoyens et puis euh ce
besoin euh aussi de circulation de
retourner dans dans les territoires dans
les territoires d'origine parce que pour
en rester dans l'Hexagone se déplacer
entre les régions c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut faire euh d'un instant à
l'autre par contre aller en are mer
c'est toute c'est toute une histoire euh
ensuite mon mon mon dernier point j'en
avais plein d'autres mais
euh
mon mon dernier point c'est par rapport
à l'utilisation des fonds européens s's
on sujet effectivement euh extrêmement
sensible et la solution que vous
préconisez c'est celle qui est
aujourd'hui en vigueur à
Mayotte c'est-à-dire confier à une
structure ad hoc une un GP la la gestion
des des des fonds européen et pourtant
ça va pas mieux ça va pas mieux et et
derrière ma ma question c'est comment
euh quelque part faire
pour
euh améliorer l'ingénierie le mot fâ
parfois euh dans certains territoires
mais c'est une réalité il y a soit une
insuffisance d'ingénierie et ça ce n'est
pas valable sur sur tous les territoires
soit une inégale répartition des des
ingénieries au sein même euh des des mêm
des mêmes territoires donc tout en en
adhérant à cette préconisation de mettre
en place une structure ad hoc pour gérer
les les fonds européens comment faire
euh pour que au sein de cette structure
nous ayons les meilleurs euh parce que
en nreomire nous aurions besoin des
meilleurs parce que la la situation est
plus compliquée qu'ailleurs euh mais
souvent ce n'est pas le cas souvent
c'est l'inverse parce que les
territoires ne sont pas attractifs donc
c'est un peu le serpent qui se mort la
queue et
et pour pour conclure ma question
c'est comment inverser comment sortir de
ce cercle vicieux et tout en allant dans
le sens des proposition que vous avez
préconisé ici merci madame la
ministre
d'accord
merci
saïame la ministre en tout cas comme
comme mes collègues et même Victorin je
crois qu' adère totalement à votre votre
vision votre expérience d'autre
[Musique]
mère problème de base c'est de savoir ce
que la France veut pour ses outremères
je dire à un moment donné dès l'instant
où on a politiquement une une vision et
et en en relève comme l'a fait Jacques
Chirac vous l'avez bien dit l'intérêt
quand nos aremes pour pour la France euh
derrière on peut décliner une politique
et une organisation administrative telle
qu'on l'a
abordé pendant C ces moments et qui me
qui me paraissent après avec des
ajustements qui me paraissent
compatibles avec cette volonté autr en
tout cas je je défendrai après je crois
qu'il y a un élément et puis c'est c'est
une discussion qu'on
a quelquesuns et vous l'avez dit en
parlant des préfets maritimes c'est
qu'il y a en fait il y a trois bassins
spécifiques donc à momenté il faudra
même si on a une politique oututremère
bien définie faudra un traitement
particulier peut-être ENF spécifique en
fonction du bassin enfin bon je viens du
bassin Pacifique c'est sûr que le bassin
Pacifique il a il a d'autres
spécificités puis en plus avec des
territoires qui ont déjà euh au au moins
en tout cas pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie
et la poisie française une certaine
autonomie hein par rapport à ce que vous
disiez entre l'État qui a conser ses
compétences régaliennes effectivement
qui qui qui met des moyens de toute
façon en compéten rgalienne et euh une
autonomie euh de décision euh pour les
élus locaux donc voilà moi c'était
simplement ce que je voulais rajouter
mais en tout cas je je suivrai euh la
suite de cette audition et en tout cas
j'attends le rapport parce que ça va
servir de base effectivement pour la
suite
de nos de nos travaux merci en tout cas
merci chers collègu donc tout de suite
je vais laisser la parole à notre
collègue Saïd Omar
olit merci madame la Présidente tout
d'abord je voudrais saluer madame la la
ministre on a eu l'occasion de
travailler ensemble j'ai beaucoup
apprécié lorsque j'étais président du
Département effectivement et je voulais
vous dire que merci de ce que vous avez
fait pour Mayot parce que le contrat de
plan est à Mayotte 2000
200006 qui a été mis en place par vous
c'est ce que nous avons réalisé depuis
et jusqu'à maintenant
rien tout était clair tout était
bien mis en œuvre et depuis
effectivement nous avons l'impression
qu'au lieu de
progresser on
recule je vais vous donner des
exemples aujourd'hui Mayot c'est euh 60
% de la population qui a moins de 20
ans
et
bizarrement je vais parler sous le
contrôle de mon amitani qui est
avocat bizarrement on a construit
beaucoup de collèges et des lycées et je
ne comprends pas qu'aujourd'hui il y a
des audiences au tribunal à Mayotte qui
ne peut pas se tenir parce qu'il y a pas
d'interprète
il y a un
problème est-ce que c'est l'éducation
qui a failli pour qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de jeunes c'est ça beaucoup de
personnes vont au tribunal bon on peut
pas les
juger deè chose que moi je je vois parce
que ça fait 22 ans de mandat local et
que j'ai vu les
choses se
passer c'est que
on n'a pas connu cette violence il
nuit et que on ne comprend pas
qu'aujourd'hui on a augmenté les
effectifs de police et de gendarmerie
d'une manière significative et en même
temps on a l'impression que plus on
augmente les effectifs et des casernes
de gendarmerie ici par là et c'est là où
il y a la violence qui ne fait
qu'augmenter alors moi la question que
je voudrais vous poser madame je
souscris tout ce que vous avez dit quel
regard vous portez sur ce qui se passe à
Mayotte aujourd'hui
ou pour la première fois dans son
histoire le départ du représentant de
l'État sur place a été demandé
publiquement notamment par une
parlementaire or Mayotte vous savez est
très rattaché à la
France je pense que depuis 1841 on na
jamais failli on a toujours réclamer
plus d'État plus de
France aujourd'hui c'est un
parlementaire qui demande le départ d'un
préfet donc il est malaise donc quel est
votre regard
oui une député de chez nous
ou bien merci beaucoup pour euh pour vos
questions alors je commencerai tout
d'abord euh par
répondre à la question que vous vous
posez monsieur le sénateur sur
faut-il avoir dans chaque ministère des
spécialistes de l'outrem est-ce que
c'est peut-être pas mieux que
d'avoir un un ministère de plein
exercice bon
euh moi j'ai vécu une
expérience qui je
crois permettait de de d'être efficace
euh sur tous les sujets je vais vous
donner des exemples précis parce que à
l'époque que j'ai connu tout le budget
consacré à l'outremère se trouvait pas
sur le budget du ministère de l'outremè
même s'il y avait beaucoup de choses le
logement il y avait tous les dossiers
enfin toutes les dépenses sociales enfin
bon mais je vais vous prendre deux
exemples
précis quand le ministère de l'intérie
le ministre de l'Intérieur de l'époque
présentait des lois de sécurité
intérieure il y avait toujours à la fin
de la loi un chapitre consacré à
l'outr-em et comment ça se passer les
administrations de mon
ministère avec celle du ministère de
l'Intérieur se concerter et rédiger un
chapitre spécifique sur l'outre mère
avec des moyens en policier en gendarme
bon c'était les fameuses glopsies vous
savez bon il y en a eu plusieurs et donc
cétait en concertation avec
l'administration de mon ministère que le
chapitre réservé à l'outremè était
rédigé et qu'est-ce qui se passait au
Parlement
le ministre de l'Intérieur défendait son
projet et quand arrivait le chapitre sur
l'outreem c'est moi qui
défendait cette partie de la loi
consacrée à l'outreem aussi bien
l'assemblée qu'au Sénat voilà comment ça
fonctionnait je vais prendre un deuxième
exemple quand nous avons révisé la
Constitution en
2003 qu'on a réécrit les articles 73 et
74 c'est le garde des
qui est compétent en matière de révision
constitutionnelle comment ça s'est passé
il a fait une présentation générale de
la révision
constitutionnelle et c'est moi en tant
que ministre de l'outrem qui a défendu
la révision au Parlement sur ces
articles sur ce titre 12 et je crois que
c'est comme ça que ça peut fonctionner
efficassement je vois pas d'ailleurs
très franchement je crois qu'on peut
faire le bil
aujourd'hui le les fonctionnaires vous
savez pourquoi voulez-vous qu'ils aient
envie d'aller s'occuper de dossier
spécifique sur l'outreemè dans un
ministère quelle attractivité ça ça
représente s'il y a pas vraiment une
administration suffisamment puissante
c'est pour ça que je suis pas comme je
dis je suis pas naïve à partir du moment
où on a supprimé ces directions on va
pas les recréer mais il faut voir
comment euh regrouper
l'outre mer et la mer par exemple il y a
des administrations importantes qui
s'occupent de la mer et je le rappelle
la mer notre domaine maritime 97 % se
trouve outre mer donc il y a des grandes
direction les pêches transports maritime
les bon si on reconstitue une entité qui
a une cohérence je pense que on arrivera
à avoir des fonctionnaires qui seront
attirés par ce ce genre de mission et et
on retrouvera une vraiment une
spécialité et on pourra à ce moment-là
injecter des chapitres sur l'outreem
dans les différentes lois qui peuvent
être présentées et là on fera l'exercice
en amont et pas en aval vous comprenez
parce que c'est au moment de la
rédaction de la loi que le que le
problème doit se régler c'est pas après
qu'on découvre que c'est complètement
inapplicable tromè parce qu'auellement
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on fait un article
pour dire est-ce que ça s'applique à la
Polynésie au aux collectivités de
l'article 74 c'est c'est c'est le seul
la seule réaction qu'on a or je crois
que c'est pas comme ça que que qu'on
peut travailler et et moi j'ai eu
l'expérience et à l'époque je vous
rappelle que c'était Nicolas Sarkozi qui
était ministre de l'Intérieur donc et
bien il m'a laissé dans ses lois de de
sécurité
intérieure défendre le chapitre outreem
qui avait été écrit en une sorte de
coécriture avec les services de
l'intérieur et deoutrem pour avoir quel
quelque chose qui était effectivement
adapté à nos
collectivités et même exemple je vous
dis sur la révision
constitutionnelle alors ensuite
euh sur
l'affectation des originaires d'outrem
dans leur territoire bon je crois que
tout ça relève d'une gestion
intelligente en fait ça sert à rien de
de d'écrire des textes des
règlements je crois que par principe
tout le monde a vocation à servir
partout
ensuite c'est pas interdit d'être
intelligent et de d'essayer de mettre
les bonnes personnes aux bons endroits
avec simplement je dis comme garde fou
attention au conflit d'intérêt parce que
là c'est c'est dommageable pour tout le
monde et puis attention à ne pas faire
de la ségrégation je veux dire il suffit
d'un dosage intelligent euh dans une
carrière on peut
servir aussi bien outre mer qu'en
métropole mais qu'on soit pas cantonné
ni outreem ni ni sur le territoire
métropolitain donc je pense que tout ça
peut se faire par une gestion fluide et
intelligente pour affecter les gens
compétents aux bons endroits et tenir
compte un petit peu de de toutes les
particularités régionales ça vaut aussi
bien pour la Bretagne et la Corse que
pour que pour des collectivités
d'outrem
euh votre collègue évoqué les bassins
effectivement il y a trois bassins
importants c'est pour ça que moi je je
propose et c'était le sens du rapport de
la Cour des comptes de créer trois
préfet maritime dans ces trois bassins
et sur
Mayotte on aurait un préfet maritime en
charge de l'océan Indien
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il aurait
d'abord beaucoup de travail et que euh
euh il s'agirait de contrôler quand même
une zone qui me paraît pas si immense
que ça
euh on peut quand même mettre de temps
en temps quelques bateaux de la Marine
nationale entre en jouant et Mayotte ce
serait quand même pas complètement
irréaliste et je pense que ça
permettrait de régler pas mal de
problèmes
donc je me permets de euh de dire
que c'est dans ce sens qu'il faudrait
aller
et mettons des gens aussi compétents
pour gérer ce territoire maritime dont
on se
désintéresse vous ce que vous avez dit
sur le le la demande de de départ du
représentant de l'État j'ai commencé mon
mon intervention en vous disant combien
j'étais choqué d'entendre ce que j'ai
entendu pendant la crise covid quand on
dit la France dehors la France
dégage moi personnellement j'ai
travaillé de longues années sur
l'outreem je n'ai jamais entendu ça
outreem donc ça révèle la profondeur du
malaise et je trouve ça très grave et
très préoccupant et si on continue comme
ça je vais vous dire je suis très
pessimiste sur l'avenir parce
que il y aura même pas besoin d'avoir
des indépendantistes pour demander
l'indépendance elle arrivera tout
naturellement parce que tout le monde se
désintéressera plus personne ne ne
défendra des crédits de pour pour ses
collectivités et voilà donc si on ne
mais tout dépend de la vision politique
qu'on a de deux choses l'une soit c'est
important soit c'est la dimension
mondiale de la France et on en tire
toutes t conséquences soit à ce
moment-là je dire on peut être très
pessimiste sur l'avenir mais s'il y a un
sursaut pour considérer que ces
collectivités sont vraiment
indispensable à notre pays ben à ce
moment-là il faut en tirer toutes les
conséquences et
rapidement c'est-à-dire renforcer
effectivement tout ce qui est régalien
et je persiste à dire que pour tout ce
qui n'est pas
régalien il faut et et ce qui s'est
passé sur le covid est
symptomatique on a voulu imposer une
politique en matière de santé en matière
de vaccin à des populations qui
n'étaient pas prêtes à entendre ce
discours et bien donnons les moyens
financiers pour gérer une politique de
santé
localement ne encore une fois
l'autonomie c'est pas ça n'a rien de
de d'extraordinaire c'est c'est vraiment
la prise en compte de de de
particularités locales laissons ceux qui
connaissent le mieux le terrain définir
eux-mêmes la politique qui doit être
mise en place et ça ne veut pas dire que
on s'en
désintéresse il faut accompagner
financièrement j'ai cité l'exemple de la
Polynésie autonome en matière de santé
on a payé les vaccins et vous n'avez pas
entendu en Polynésie de problèmes au
moment de la crise covid on n pas il y a
pas eu de
de on n'a pas entendu ce qu'on a entendu
aux Antilles pour être clair et ce que
vous me dites sur Mayotte est est est
vraiment euh effectivement très
préoccupant et c'est pour ça que je
pense que il y a urgence à avoir un
sursaut parce que sinon
euh je veux pas faire de parallèle mais
si on se met à fermer une préfecture euh
c'est
grave merci madame la la ministre je
voudrais revenir sur un point que vous
avez abordé sur les compétences des
fonctionnaires dans dans les
ministère je me suis rendu à à Toulouse
à l'Institut national des études
territoriales et j'étais frappé de voir
que
euh seul cinq
ultramarins faisaient partie de la
promotion en cours avaent réussi le
concours dans quatre ingénieurs donc
pour rejoindre le collègue tan Mohamed
qui qui déplore le manque d'ingénierie
et nous avons des des des ingénieurs
ultramarins mais peut-être pas assez qui
sont intégré dans des administrations
parallèlement
euh madame madame buriel jaltan lors de
son parcours à sciencep
avait noté relevé que la formation le
cursus sur
l'outrem était considérablement réduit
elle a travaillé à un projet de cher
outreem qui a été porté par par Michel
Magra dans la loi de 2017 et qui a été
inauguré le 8 juillet 2021
malheureusement donc le but de cette
chair outremère c'était justement en
partie de permettre aux fonctionnaires
des différents ministères de pouvoir
suivre une formation approfondie pour
mieux appréhender les réalités les
spécificités des territoire
malheureusement cette chair outremère
n'a pas évolué comme comme elle l'aurait
elle été un peu dévoyée j'aurais mais
savoir est-ce que vous pensiez que l'on
puisse intégrer enfin rendre obligatoire
euh une formation euh dont pour
permettre justement à tous les étudiants
qui ne concne pas spécifiquement les
étudiants ultrammarins mais à tous les
étudiants de suivre un cursus
obligatoire dans leur formation sur les
territoires ultrarins et pourquoi pas
partir en stage dans les territoires
pour mieux appréhender le fonctionnement
de de ces territoires puisque comme vous
l'avez fort justement dit chaque
territoire a ses propres spécificités
ses
réalités moi très franchement je je ne
peux être que favorable à ce genre
d'initiative mais encore une fois il
faut que après il y ait des
débouchés il faut pas que que ça a un
caractère excusez-moi deexpression mais
un peu exotique quoi il faut que
derrière il y ait la possibilité de de
d'avoir voir des des fonctions qui
soient
valorisantes donc c'est c'est un peu ça
le problème moi je suis tout à fait
favorable à ce que on
inscrive ce genre de cursus obligatoire
pourquoi pas moi j'avis toujours été
frappé quand mes enfants étaient à
l'école primaire et qui avait qui avait
un cours de
géographie sur la France ultramarine
j'étais effondrée de voir que la moitié
des collectivités qui étaient passées
sous silence que bon il y a aussi cet
effort à faire en métropole pour faire
connaître ces territoires et et dans
notre enseignement c'est effectivement
quelque chose qui est assez passé sous
silence mais bon encore une fois c'est
une politique globale qu'il faut avoir
si on veut vraiment
euh faire en sorte que ces ces
collectivités soient soi bien traité bah
non seulement il il faut s'en occuper
mais enfin il faut avoir la conviction
que elles sont utiles à la France et que
sans elles la France ne serait pas la
France Merci euh si les les collègues
ont-ils quelque chose à rajouter
messieur les rapporteurs monsieur bas
merci Victor Lurel ça va c'est très bon
c'est
parfait je ne résiste pas à à l'envie de
de rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
madame la ministre à savoir euh la la
nécessité de faire mieux connaître les
les les autres maires
euh combien de fois on entend euh
notamment dans les r les fameux réseaux
sociaux
lorsque il y a des crises et notamment
la crise de Mayotte actuellement on
entend et n qu'à prendre leur
indépendance euh euh ce ne sont pas des
ce ne sont pas des Français
euh outre le fait que ça fait mal
lorsqu'on on on connaît avec quel
acharnement les maorés avant ni et la
savoi euh pour des raisons de liberté
euh se sont
attachés à à à la France euh ça ça ce
genre de réflexion part d'une
méconnaissance grass euh de de ce que
sont les les les outres mèes euh et et
comment défendre des territoires si on
ne les fait pas mieux connaître donc
c'était juste pour aller dans votre sens
et illustrer à quel point
effectivement il y a ce béabas cette
nécessité de mieux faire connaître le
territoire je vais vous donner aussi un
exemple qui m'a frappé dans l'actualité
ces derniers jours parce que tout le
monde doit faire des efforts à commencé
aussi par les médias bon quand il y a eu
le récent cyclone à la réunion j'ai
entendu des commentaires sur le thème
bah tout ça c'est le réchauffement
climatique comme les inondations dans le
Pas de calé vous avez un exemple de la
méconnaissance totale du fait que
outreer les cylone il y en a toujours eu
que ça fait partie des handicaps
structurels de ces collectivités et que
avec ou sans réchauffement climatique il
y a toujours des cyclones donc assimiler
et et dans dans toutes les ZES puis bon
même dans certaines conférences de
presse j'ai entendu ce genre de de
rapprochement bon je trouve que ça
illustre le la méconnaissance totale de
de de nos collectivités et
bon je voudrais qu'on ne soit pas les
derniers à se battre pour leur
reconnaissance et c'est vrai que de
temps en temps c'est un petit
peu c'est un petit peu
triste je je me permets de avec
l'autorisation de notre présidente de
rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être dit je
crois que c'est très
important que nos compatriotes
d'outreem qui ne sont ni plus ni moins
français que nos autres compatriotes
entendent que l'attachement de la France
aux outr m n'est pas principalement
dicté par des considérations
stratégiques mais tout simplement par le
fait irréfutable que nous sommes tous
français je crois que ça c'est
absolument essentiel parce que
si l'outrem français repose sur un
intérêt stratégique de la métropole ça
veut dire que si cet intérêt n'existait
plus alors nous n'aurions aucun mal à
répondre à ces slogans que en effet le
jour peut-être
venu de se
séparer
et le meilleur moyen d'exclure
radicalement cette perspective c'est
juste de rappeler que nous sommes tous
français merci merci avant de clore
cette cette audition non je vais je vais
rappeler je vais noter que vous avez
relevé deux
axes qui semblent important pour essayer
de de mieux appréhender les les les
problématiques ultramarines donc il nous
faudra un ministère de plein plein d'
exercice avec deux grandes directions
donc l'une concernant le régalien
l'administration et la gestion du du du
régalien mieux adapté le régalien aux
réalités des territoires et une deuxième
liée à l'action de de l'État en mer en N
trois préfectures trois préfets
maritimes une administration solide avec
des fonctionnaires compétents qui
seraient directement rattachés au
président de la République et le deème
axe qui est un axe un peu plus
institutionnel voire constitutionnel
avec une
révision une réécriture des articles 73
et 74 permettant donnant une plus de
souplesse et permettant aussi aux
collectivités d'adapter euh leur leur
caractère d'adapter leur développement
d'avoir plusurs responsabilité et et de
s'adapter au aux caractéristiques et
contraintes de leur territoire euh
propre je dois vous avouer que j'y Ada
complètement que c'était aussi le cheval
de bataille de mon prédécesseur Michel
Magra que je poursuis aussi dans dans
cette voie et je vous remercie
infiniment pour votre expertise et votes
éclairages sur en mettant en avant des
exemples concrets euh et j'espère que
nous serons entendus et que vous serez
entendu c'est aussi le rôle de la
délégation de permettre à travers ces
travaux de mieux euh connaître les
réalités les territoires ultramarins et
j'en profite pour passer une petite
annonce auprès de des collègues le 27
février à 18h en salle mdicis j'invite
tous les collègues ultramarins à
présenter chacun leur territoire aux
collègues aux autres collègues de la
délégation mais à tous ceux tous les
collègues du Sénat qui veulent y
assister ainsi qu'aux administrateurs
parce qu' aussi on a besoin que les
administrateurs apprendent mieux les
réalités des territoires je vous
remercie
bien